all right we have we have several things
to talk about today Elizabeth Warren is
telling stories again she's making up
fables the it's become its own genre now
of warren fables she loves to tell them
and and so we're gonna talk about that
also a group of parents are suing a
video game developer because they say
that their kids are addicted to video
games we're going to discuss this and
what we'll try to get to the bottom of
is is this question you know if you're
if you're a parent and your kids are
playing too many video games what's the
best way to handle that yeah you could
sue the video game company but is there
a more direct and possibly less
expensive path you could take to control
how much time your kids space spend
playing video games well we'll talk
about that also justin trudeau you know
that i love justin trudeau videos on
this show he is a source of neverending
hilarity and I have now what I think is
not just the most hilarious trudeau
video yet but I think that maybe the
most hilarious video to ever be posted
on the Internet and I don't think I'm
hyping that up too much maybe a little
bit too much but but not by much so
we're gonna talk about all that today
and more but first a word from Rock Auto
you know chain stores have here's the
thing about chain stores they have
different price price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers rockauto.com prices
though are the same for everybody and
that is there reliably low for everybody
no matter who you are rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear it's
kinda like what airlines do rockauto.com
doesn't do that rockauto.com is for
everybody doesn't require membership
doesn't require login rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto part
customers online for 20 years they've
been doing this go to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
brake parts tail lamps motor oil even
new carpet if you need it whether it's
for your classic or your daily driver
get everything you need in a few easy
click clicks the thing that I love about
Rock Auto is it's extremely well
organized when you go to the site very
easy to navigate
so you find you know what you're finding
there it's easy to find you know it's
gonna be the best price that you can get
anywhere
they'll ship it right to your door so
you don't have to wander around an auto
parts store no more of that just go to
Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your car truck and
remember to write Walsh into there how
did you hear about us box so that they
know that we sent you again that's
rockauto.com okay so before we get to
the warning thing just a another thought
on this issue with the NBA in China at
this point all of the NBA's Chinese
partners according to CNN all of them
have now cut ties with the NBA because
of one tweet sent by one guy in that
works for one team one tweet saying
fight for freedom sent by one employee
on one basketball team has led to all
this I read somewhere that the NBA
stands to lose like a billion dollars a
billion dollars they stand to lose
because of this one tweet now I want you
to think about that for a second think
about how China is reacting to one tweet
sent by one guy in Texas they're just
coming down like an avalanche of bricks
they're coming down on the NBA for this
and even though the NBA is groveling and
apologizing and licking their boots
uh they're they're they're being
punished now you think about that now
consider what it must be like to
actually live as a citizen in this
country entirely subject to the whims of
the communist government imagine if you
were a citizen who sent out that tweet
China has
has brought all of its forces to bear to
punish the NBA multibillion-dollar
American company now think about if
you're just a lowly Chinese citizen
expressing your free speech rights which
which of course you don't actually have
free speech rights in China and that's
exactly the point
so in conclusion communism is bad folks
communism is very very very bad not just
bad in practice not just bad when
instituted incorrectly which just so
happens to be every single time it's
been instituted according to some people
it's always incorrect it's never the
real communism but no that's not it see
communism is bad to its core it is bad
in theory it is bad in practice it is
bad as an idea is bad as a policy it is
bad all around because there is no room
for freedom in communism and that's the
point as we are clearly seeing freedom
and and communism are in two different
directions freedom is that way and
communism is that way going in two
different directions now I know that
this should all be obvious it's it's
it's not I'm I'm not the first person to
point out that communism is bad but it
does unfortunately need to be pointed
out because it seems that it's not
obvious to a lot of people in this
country according to any survey that's
been done recently on the subject a
large percentage of Millennials I read
one survey that claimed it was like half
of Millennials 50% around there have a
positive view of communism so that's why
we have to point to this and state the
obvious that here's what communism is
this is why it's a terrible thing that
doesn't mean that capitalism is flawless
that there are no problems with it that
you could point out of course there are
it is a human system it's a human
economic system and so it's going to be
flawed and there are going to be
downsides to it that's the way it is
with any human institution or human
system but communism is evil to its core
yet people a lot of people my generation
they
faith that communism is a beautiful and
wonderful thing and that faith in doors
despite all evidence every example we
have of communism throughout history and
in the world currently it's all terrible
but there's this faith that people have
that they say well no it's still you
know it's it's it's still this great
idea we're just waiting for it's it's
it's it's full and correct manifestation
no this is Chinese communism is
communism this is the this is the
correct version this is real communism
and this is what communism is and all of
its glory or lack thereof I think it's
important for us to realize that all
right so Elizabeth Warren is up to her
old tricks again it seems possibly
telling stories that are possibly not
altogether true lies would be another
way of putting it a less polite way
Warren on the campaign trail likes to
claim that she was fired from a teaching
job in 1971 for being visibly pregnant
and she's told the story countless times
turns out shock of the century maybe not
exactly true there are two things that
contradict her story the first thing is
herself she herself has contradicted the
story because she has told this story of
leaving the teaching job very
differently in the past there are kind
of two different versions of it so let's
look at this students for Trump put out
they put together a comparison of how
Warren tells the story now in 2019 verse
how she told it ten years ago and
there's a there's a not so subtle
difference watch this so my first
teaching position was as a special needs
teacher there we go I worked it was in a
public school system but I worked with
the the children with disabilities I
loved that job but by the end of the
first school year I was quite visibly
pregnant and I was pregnant with my
first baby so I had a baby and stayed
home for a couple of years and I was
really caz
Anabelle thinking what am I going to do
and my husband's view of it was Sam and
the principal didn't invite me back for
the next school year
and I did that for a year and then that
summer I actually didn't have the
education courses so I was on an
emergency certificate it was called and
I went back to graduate school and took
a couple of courses in education and
said I don't think this is going to work
out for me okay two versions here in
both versions she ends up not having the
job so that's the conclusion and that's
the same in both cases but in one case
she's fired or at least not invited back
because she's pregnant and in the other
case she leads on her own accord there's
a principle here that is that's very
helpful I think which says that if a
story changes over time you can
generally be confident that the earlier
version of the story is going to be
correct because that's how stories
stories usually grow in the telling and
they become more dramatic and more
elaborate not the other way around and
so if we have to choose between the two
versions of the story it seems like
probably the one she told ten years ago
is the correct one but we don't even
need to guess there's no guesswork here
because the Washington free beacon has
come with receipts they have well let me
read a little bit of their report the
Washington free beacon says minutes
minutes of an April 21st 1971 Riverdale
Board of Education meeting obtained by
the Washington free beacon show that the
board voted unanimously on a motion to
extend Warren a second year contract for
two days of per week teaching job that
job is similar to the one she held the
previous year her first year of teaching
minutes from a board meeting held two
months later on June 16th 1971 indicate
that Warren's resignation was quote
accepted with regrets so that would seem
to be pretty conclusive the story she
told ten years ago matches the
documentation the latest story does not
I'm not going to say she's lying though
let's just say that it is a loose
interpretation of an event or an li e
for short let's just say that now here's
really what I want to talk about let's
let's put Warren's
fibs to the side here for a moment
because what the issue we're talking
about here is how pregnant women are
treated in the workforce and and and how
much they are accepted in society and
how much we accommodate and all of that
I totally agree that pregnant women
should be accepted and accommodated as
much as feasible we should make it as a
society easier not harder for people to
have kids and to grow their families and
and so on
you know we pro-lifers we on the rights
who who are pro-life we're the ones who
are all about welcoming and accepting
pregnancy new life mothers families you
know that's our thing we we're all about
that um we we can't let the left claim
that as their own like this is their
hobbyhorse it isn't you see the left
pretends to care about pregnant women
but really what they're doing is they're
using pregnant women much like elizabeth
warren uses this story that she it would
seem made-up they use it as a means to
an end and on the left it everything is
a means to an end
especially women and especially pregnant
women most of all of all the people they
enjoy using politically probably there's
no group that they enjoy using more than
pregnant women because for the left it's
all about control for the state and
everything comes back to that and that's
the end that everything for which
everything is being used so whereas I
would say I think it's very good for
companies if they can to offer maternity
leave and the more generous the leave
the better I think that's a great thing
that's what I would say and and that's
what most people on the right would say
but then the left comes in like Kamala
Harris a few days ago she said this is
literally her plan she said that there
should be six months of paid family
leave that all companies should be
required to offer
she wants the state to impose as
mandatory six months of paid family
leave now that obviously is absurd and
when we say that up that's absurd we're
going to be accused by the left vote you
don't care about families and pregnant
you say you're pro-life but no because
many companies simply cannot afford that
they simply cannot afford to pay someone
to not work for half a year there are
basic financial realities here and they
can't afford to hire someone if you
leave you're gonna leave for six months
and come back that means they need to
hire someone for six months to do your
job that they're gonna pay and then
they're also paying you to not do the
job and so they're paying the jet for
the job twice it's double to pay for six
months they can't afford it but the left
likes plans like that because it
represents an enormous amount of control
by the state over private enterprise and
because of course companies can't afford
this that means that they're going to
need to rely on the state there's going
to need to be a you know a subsidy kind
of situation where the state is
subsidizing this and that's even more
control for the state and that's what it
always comes back to pregnant women are
a means to an end and the end is state
control that's it that's always it
that's what it always comes back to
because on the on the basic point that
again we should be in comedy
accommodating and accepting as much as
possible of pregnant women we should be
welcoming of that and celebrate that
that there's no disagreement in fact
we're the one we are the ones as
pro-lifers that's how we really feel
about it we really do see pregnancy as a
beautiful and miraculous thing it's the
left that says that a pregnant woman is
basically a pregnant woman is it she
basically has a tapeworm infestation
because what she has is a parasite in
her body that she could expel or destroy
at any time and it wouldn't matter its
what the left says it's not us yet we
also recognize certain realities and
although it would be nice I mean
it would be nice if when a woman gets
pregnant has a kid it'd be nice if she
could take off for five years and get
paid and take off until the kid goes
into kindergarten spend those five years
with their family and get paid the whole
time that would be fantastic right may I
mean who wouldn't like a deal like
that'd be really great but it's it's not
possible because there is this thing
called reality and it just wouldn't work
because that money has to come from
somewhere someone has to pay it as my
dad always told me money doesn't grow on
trees and so there's no there's no
magical money tree that money's got to
come from somewhere either you're gonna
be bankrupting a company by forcing them
to pay it for someone who's not working
or it's the state's gonna come in and I
basically take over okay a couple of
funny videos to play for you real quick
before we get to this video game topic
first I well I'm not really sure what
this is I think it's an environmental
it's another environmentalist protest a
climate protest in London I believe but
the video I guess speaks for itself
watch this
[Music]
and I watch that and I'm really
concerned because those people are
clearly having seizures and everyone
else is just standing around rather than
calling an ambulance but I guess they
can't get the ambulance there because
they're also blocking the road when
they're having their seizures so that's
sort of sort of disturbing to watch but
if you keep playing the video so it you
know you you saw their dance moves but
you keep playing the video for a few
more seconds and I was really surprised
when this happened
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so there you go
great great dancing all around who do
you think is a better dancer Spicer or
the hippies that's a tough call I if I
had to choose I may be technically
Spicer's a little bit of a better dancer
he is choreographed at least I wouldn't
go anywhere near close to saying that
he's a technically good dancer because
he's not but but I think technically
he's got it over the hippies but it you
know the hippies are also there's more
life to what they're doing mostly
because of all the drugs they're on but
you know I to me it feels freer more in
the moment so I don't know it's it's a
tough call between those two all right
forget about all that actually because
without further ado I wanna finally play
what I think is maybe the funniest video
ever recorded and I I hope I'm not
overselling it too much but this is
brilliant watch and solarath I'm gonna
stand up and ask a question what did you
paint your face down ooh
it was something I shouldn't have done
does it hurt people um it's not
something that you you should do and
that is something that I learned I
didn't know it back then but I know it
now
and I'm sorry I hurt people but did you
pick your notes and your hands man
mm-hmm and it was the wrong thing to do
I just I I love everything about that
video I I love The awkward pause at the
end it's like something out of the
office but in real life it's it's great
and you know what I think happened here
because a lot of people I post this
video last night on Twitter a lot of
people were saying oh this is staged
it's clearly he staged it he he had
these two young girls ask this question
so he could give his canned response and
I I think probably that is what happened
I think the first part was staged which
is but it's still hilarious actually
makes it funnier
because he comes off like a clown he
staged he staged this thing where
somebody would ask him an embarrassing
question and he still came off really
awkward and funny but then it seems to
me if I I don't want to speculate too
much but it seems like the follow-up
question from the girls was off script
so that's that's my guess is that they
were coached okay stand up ask this
question of the nice Prime Minister and
then sit down and but they're kids so
you know they stood up they asked the
question they were told asked and then
they started ad libbing a little bit and
that's where Trudeau got flustered
that's where they awkward pause came in
because when they said but did you paint
your nose and hands Brown too and that's
where you get the pause where he's going
mm-hmm sit down sir it's just uh it's
amazing I love that so that's great
that brings a smile to my face and not
many things do these days all right um I
almost I gotta say because I'm I don't
live in Canada and it's no skin off my
nose so no offense to Canadians but I
really hope that Justin Trudeau stays in
office for as long as as possible
I just I hope that he's in office for
the next 50 years because he's such a
source of of joy for me personally okay
now what I want to read now from a
little bit from the u.s. from from
usatoday.com an article about a about a
certain lawsuit that brings up an
interesting question the article says
roughly a quarter of a billion mostly
obsessed gamers are battling it out on
fortnight there's a darn decent chance
kids you know are among them this again
is a this is a USA Today article and and
it says there's a uses the word darn
darn decent chance and aus okay anyway
this is journalism for you a Montreal
based law firm launched a proposed
class-action lawsuit in Canada on behalf
of to Quebec parents who claim that
Fortnite publisher epic games needs to
pay the price for a third-person shooter
they allege is as
addictive and potentially harmful as
cocaine the firm collects legal
represents plaintiffs who are identified
only by their initials FN and jay-z
not not that jay-z different jay-z there
they're the parents of a 10 and 15 year
old respectively written in French the
legal action alleges that when a person
is engaged in fortnight for a long
period the player's brain releases the
pleasure hormone dopamine and that
fortnight was developed by psychologist
statistician and others over four years
to develop the most addictive game
possible also epic could reap lucrative
profits so the accusation here very
startling accusation what they are
alleging get this is that the developers
of fortnight tried to make a game that
people would really want to play if you
can believe it now I've heard stories I
can't confirm this but I've heard
stories that you know clothing companies
will oftentimes get together and and
come up with with with schemes of you
know how can they make clothing that
people are really gonna want to wear
I've even heard fast-food companies that
they'll sit around I imagine in darkened
rooms with smoke billowing from their
cigars and and they they're sitting
there and then they're saying that
they're concocting these plans to come
up with food that people will really
want to keep eating
so that's anyway that's the allegation
I'm not sure or not but it does raise
this question of ok you're a parent and
your kid plays video games way too much
he's 10 years old as one of these kids
is what can you do about it
and this is a relevant question because
although there's only two parents right
now involved in this proposed
class-action lawsuit there are lots of
other parents out there who complain
about this in fact I get emails
sometimes I talk about video games
sometimes and you know the pros and cons
of video games mostly I talked about the
cons really but and I'll sometimes get
emails from parents talking about how
their kids play video games way too much
and they don't
don't know what to do about it so this
is a this is a problem a lot of parents
have so what do you do if your kid plays
is playing video games all day here's my
idea I mean yeah you could file a
lawsuit you could complain you know to
somebody like me you could shake your
fist at the heavens you could cry
yourself to sleep all of these
strategies could work
maybe but here's a different idea maybe
your kids playing video games all day
maybe we could do is stop allowing him
to play video games all day there's an
idea
so all these parents or I don't know to
do my I don't know to do my kids they
play video games they they they've
they're on their phone all the time what
do I do about this
you know maybe be a parent possibly just
do a little parenting have you
considered that just as that thought
have you sat down maybe with your spouse
and talked about this and you said hey
maybe you think we should do some
parenting actually for a change here
maybe we've had this kid for 10 years we
haven't parented him yet do you think
maybe it's time I all sarcasm aside as
as difficult as it is for me to do I
really don't understand I just I don't
get parents who act like these neutered
puppy dogs like the ineffectual impotent
they they have no ability that you are
the parents you control everything in
your house everything that's in your
house you bought with your money your
kid doesn't have anything unless they're
much older they have a job or whatever
but that's not that's mostly not what
we're talking about here they wanted
taken the example the ten-year-old kid
everything that ten-year-old child has
it's because you bought it for him or
for a few of those things maybe someone
bought it as a gift or whatever but
almost everything you bought it probably
the
you bought the video game system you
bought the video game you bought the
clothes on his back you bought the the
the couch that he's sitting in when he
plays the games you bought the
electricity that feeds the TV that
allows him to play the vidiians you
bought all of that you control all of it
just exercise your control as a parent
it's not hard what is this oh I told him
not to and he still does it what how is
that an option he's 10 how is it even an
option for him to do it have you told
him not to take the you know what take
the video game remove it from the system
throw it in the garbage can or break it
first so we can't just take it and smash
it if you have to take the TV outside
and if there's really if there's no
other way if he really is addicted and
you can't stop him take the freakin TV
and smash it in the driveway that's I
mean that's not you could do that it's
legal it's yours you can do whatever you
want with it and it's fun too to smash
your TV have you ever tried it it's a
lot of fun I just don't get this III
really don't mean I understand that kids
don't always listen to us as parents and
we can't control everything they do
especially when they're not around us
they go to school or whatever they're
with their friends they're not our
puppets on a string right they have free
will they make choices and decisions and
all of that so I I understand all of
that but but when it comes to the things
that they spend all day doing in your
home and when it comes to the products
that they use you have so much control
over that I mean forget about smashing
the TV or taking the video game away you
could just not buy it in the first place
that is also an option and I know that
the kid will say oh but all my friends
are playing it who cares why is that a
convincing argument for my kid I hear
this from parents parents who are really
concerned that they have to buy their
kid the latest gadget or phone or video
game because all their friends have it
how are you as a parent concerned about
that why do you care you're telling me
that your your
child goes to you and says oh I want
this and you say now I don't know and
your child goes well all my friends have
it and that convinces you you're
convinced by that you say oh well all
your friends have well okay well in that
case go ahead and go I will let me let
me go right now we drop everything I'm
doing right now and grab me why didn't
you say earlier your friends do it too
well jeez hey Dad I want to go shoot up
heroin in a back alley well no you can't
do that no shoot okay well my my friends
are doing it though oh well they are ok
well then go ahead I'll Drive which back
alley I'll Drive you
oh you want to hitch a ride with someone
first let's go ahead are your friends
doing it too oh well then go ahead wait
what is that I just I don't understand
it I just have some control over your
paint over your freakin kids ok do
society a favor just say no every once
in a while you know every once in a
while at least just start with that
every once in a while when they want to
do something tell them no just for the
sake of it sometimes I think sometimes
it's good to say no to a kid just just
because you don't even have a good
reason maybe sometimes my kids will come
to his a I can I have a snack and and
and I'll say no not right now
and it'll say oh why can't I have a
snack well just because just cuz you
can't I don't know you just can't
because I'm the father and I decided
that right now you're not having a snack
because this is my house in my kitchen
in my food and I decided that right now
you're not eating it you can eat it
later
but right now you're not that's my
entire reason I have no other reason and
you're gonna respect that because you're
my child and that's the way this
relationship works I don't have to
explain myself to you I don't have to
justify myself I am the adult you are
the child that's the relationship
all right let's um let's go to emails
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt well
show at gmail.com this is from Travis as
dear fearless bearded dictator
congratulations on the birth of your
fourth child I to him in the for kid
Club here's my
advice when things get crazy fall on the
floor and play dead the kids will then
start to crawl all over you other
options to run out of the house and
start screaming you may want to put tape
over your mouth if you live in town
otherwise the neighbors will think
you're nuts the best part of having four
kids is each child has a play playmate
to congratulations again
yeah all of those strategies I have
already tried and to varying effect this
is from Allison says hi mat Congrats on
the new baby my family is very excited
for your family actually my family also
consists of two girls and two boys plus
me and my husband have you started to
get the comments yet I never got
comments or looks until we had our
fourth and some people react almost
disgusted that we have so many kids has
that been your experience yeah I was
just I was talking about this last night
and I was talking like this was my wife
too and and and she was saying if she
already is getting looks and comments
and she actually did use the word
disgusted and I think that this just
shows you why the West is dying honestly
because for kids is not a lot and I do
believe this is this is somewhat
geographically based it kind of depends
on where you live there are some places
in in the country you could live and
have four kids and if anything people
you look weird at you because you don't
have enough kids like in Utah for
example but depending on where you live
it can change and I think in a lot of
places certainly more liberal kinds of
places yeah having four kids people look
at you like you're a Ripley's Believe It
or Not exhibit and but for kids is
that's not a big family really I don't
think you count as a big than I have you
know so I don't think I wouldn't I would
say that I have a moderately sized
family at this point with four kids I
think a big family you you reach big
family territory when you can no longer
fit inside a standard minivan once
you've gotten once you have to go buy a
special van to fit all your your kids
that is a big family I think that's the
that's the cutoff so that's not you know
my my sister has nine kids my brother's
wife my sister-in-law comes from a
family I think of twelve kids I believe
and there are much bigger families
out there than that even a family of six
is not that big but we've gotten so used
to families that are below replacement
rate the families with their 1.7 kids or
whatever it is now that we really that
we see a just normal sized family as
somehow bizarre and that is not a good
sign for the future of our civilization
actually it's been kind of interesting
because everyone told me that this is
what I heard from many people that when
you hit four kids that's when you start
hearing the classic comments like oh
looks like you got your hands full or
but you need to get a TV or do you know
what causes that or you know all of
those any family with a lot of kids you
you know you know all the comments you
get from people and I always heard that
once you hit four that's when the
comments start coming in and that has
been exactly my experience it's actually
been pretty amazing I've had four kids
for a week and I've already heard all of
those comments in fact I the the you
look like you have your hands full one I
got that eight hours after the fourth
kid was born in the food court of the
hospital I got the it looks like he got
your hands full and I never got that one
time with three kids not once all of
those comments I'd never heard once
directed at me fourth kid comes and
immediately it's like it's like the you
know turning on a tap or something and
all they all come doesn't offend me or
anything I actually I'm impressed by how
on the money those predictions were so
also coming at you know I come from a
family of eight I had five siblings four
sisters one brother and so we grew up in
a pretty liberal area so the comments
and the looks and everything I got used
to that as a kid so I'm kind of
impervious to it now doesn't bother me
that much and of course also we should
remember that not every comment that a
person people can make comments that are
kind of awkward and might be annoying
because you've heard them a million
times doesn't mean they're malicious so
when someone says I'll tell you got your
hands full I don't that's not an insult
necessarily it could be it could be a
passive-aggressive way of telling you
hey
your kids but maybe not necessarily so
not all those comments are in any sense
malicious but the fact is and people who
don't have a lot of kids or don't come
from large families when they hear this
sometimes they don't believe it but the
it is true that big families forget
depending on where they live
you do get actual dirty looks and
malicious mean comments from people it's
it's kind of amazing if you've never
experienced it you think I know what
someone really come up to you
some stranger come up to you and make a
make a a malicious comment about how
many kids you have
yeah people do that they actually do it
believe it or not but who cares all
right from Nate says I like your show
when you stick to the issues but when
you go on and on about some story
related to your kids or Wi-Fi tuned out
I don't care enough about your personal
life to listen to that stick to the
topics people care about well Nate thank
you so much for that email and that
feedback I want to assure you that your
feedback means a lot to me I'm going to
take it into account and make sure to do
the exact opposite of what you have
suggested I have to assume Nate that
this is reverse psychology I have to
assume that you actually want me you
can't get enough of me rambling about my
kids and wife and you want me to do it
more because you must know that the
number one way to ensure that I talk
more about something is to send me a
snide email demanding that I talk less
about it the moment someone says to me
don't talk about this I'm gonna talk
about it even more is that a mature way
to respond on my part no but I'm not a
mature person you should know that by
now so yes now I'm going to tell more
stories about my family out of spite out
of spite against you personally that's
the way this goes or you know you could
just stop listening entirely that also
is an option I welcome you to explore
that option
it always amazes me when I get emails
from people so I got I don't like it
when you you spend too much time talking
about this or that well then don't
listen I I don't it's never occurred to
me look there are so many podcasts out
there and you know these it's a
wonderful thing there's so many podcasts
so many options there's a podcast on any
topic imaginable it's it's never
occurred to me to listen to a podcast
with content that I don't find
interesting and then write an email to
the host of that podcast telling them to
change the content because I personally
don't like it it's just I I would never
do that it's such a weird thing to do
you know there there are home
improvement podcasts out there I don't
personally care to listen to a home
improvement podcast I would never write
an email to somebody with a home
improvement podcast I'd stop talking
about this I personally find it
uninteresting I just wouldn't do that
okay from Lewis says hi Matt honest
question how do you justify going to see
a movie like Joker when you're a
Christian why expose yourself to that
debauchery and violence I don't get it
that movie like most Hollywood movies
exists only at the glorified sin and yet
you encourage people to go see it you
are not being a good shepherd of souls
just being honest well Lewis you say
that and I got a few emails like this
after talking about the Joker yesterday
you say that the movie exists to glorify
sin did you come to that conclusion from
seeing it did you actually watch it
before deciding that it only exists to
glorify sin that's quite an indictment
of the movie it could be true I am NOT
saying that there are movies that like
that out there but I do agree with you
on that score but how do you know that
this movie is one of them I assume that
you haven't seen it since you're taking
issue with the fact that I saw it at all
so I the very fact that I watched it
you're saying I can't be justified as a
Christian which tells me you haven't
watched it which tells me that you have
come to the conclusion about
the main purpose of this movie based on
what the name a preview did you even
watch it you see you saw two minute
preview when you came at it what are you
basing us on I'm really I'm perplexed
and it sounds like you're taking the
position based on your email that
Christian should just never expose
themselves to violence and debauchery in
any context that seems to be your point
not trying to make a straw man here
because but but if you thought that
there could be a context where it's okay
to for Christian to expose themselves to
this kind of content then you wouldn't
be making these judgments about a movie
you haven't seen so I can only assume
that what you know about this movie is
that there's violence in it and
debauchery as you say although I don't
know if the bond trees really well I
guess there's debauchery others so you
know that about this movie and you're
saying based on that alone don't watch
it which seems to be mean what you're
arguing is that we should just not
expose ourselves to that stuff at all
and and you're not alone in that view by
the way a lot of Christians feel that
way but I disagree with it
first of all I'll tell you why I
disagree first of all I know it's not
exactly the same but it should be
mentioned that the Bible the Old
Testament in particular contains a lot
of very bloody and gory violence and sex
and debauchery and rape and incest and
so on I mean if you were to make the
Bible into a movie you'll be a very long
movie but if you were to make it into an
accurate movie it would be nc-17 at a
minimum because of the content in it and
that's the truth yet you would say and I
agree okay you would say well that's
different
because you know it's okay
to expose yourself to the violence and
debauchery and gore and death and blood
and incest and rape and everything in
the Bible it's different you expose
yourself to that is okay
of the context now I'm not suggesting
that the Joker is like the Bible or
something I'm not saying that I'm simply
establishing that context matters and
and and so it would seem like you
actually would agree with that because
you know it's okay in the Bible context
it's all about the context and that
would mean that a statement like
Christians shouldn't expose themselves
to violence is actually a meaningless
statement it's a silly statement because
of course there are some contexts where
it's okay to do so I think you have to
abandon that general position that you
seem to be taking and find a more
nuanced one and here's the more nuanced
one which you did touch on Christians
should not engage in the glorification
of violence and sin and that's true
you know I they shouldn't I agree with
that but not every movie that depicts
violence glorifies it and and I think
there is a place for art that deals with
and depicts and discusses and wrestles
with very serious adult things like
violence and sex and all of that kids
should not be watching that but as
adults as much mature adults if we can
handle it there can be a value in it as
long as it is not the glorification but
you you seem to be conflating as again a
lot of Christians do I found you're
conflating the depiction of violence
with the glorification of it and those
are not the same things and you know why
would you depict violence in art well
because it's part of life right and and
art at its best helps you to understand
life more art if it is art has to
reflect life in in some way and and and
hopefully if it's really good art you
you after being exposed to it whatever
kind of art it is you leave with a
somewhat greater insight into certain
facets of life now I'm not gonna try to
flip this around and say that you know
no actually Christians have an
obligation to go see Joker
that's how good
no I'm not I wouldn't go quite that far
in fact I would put this movie aside for
a minute because there's a discussion
that can be had about whether or not
this movie does engage in glorification
or violence I don't think it does but it
is at least complex enough that you
would have to watch it before before
arriving at any sort of informed
conclusion but putting this aside for a
minute I just I think it's a mistake for
Christians to retreat entirely from
forms of art that deal with difficult
things I think this is a trend in
Christianity that's been going on for
decades now I think it's a very bad
trend the attitude that you know you
should only watch Kirk Cameron movies or
wait for the next God is not dead
installment and watch that sort of thing
which you should only listen to the to
the sorts of music they would you adhere
to megachurch that attitude is I think
very damaging to the faith because it
makes Christians frankly more shallow
and more bland
not to mention less engaged in the
culture as it turns out there are
actually non-christian artists out there
who have insights to offer who actually
have wisdom and artistic brilliance even
I've it's no secret that I think
Breaking Bad is the best television show
ever produced in history and Vince
Gilligan the creator of that show is not
a Christian I think he might be an
atheist actually or agnostic I'm not
sure exactly but he's certainly not a
Christian and yet he brings more moral
insight into that show and he says more
about human nature than any Christian
movie ever has and it's not close I mean
there simply is no Christian movie or
show that comes anywhere even close to
the depth of moral insight offered by a
show like Breaking Bad now it doesn't
have to be this way Christian artists
used to have more depth
that was because they they didn't always
try to keep everything PG and they
understood that that not all art has to
be appropriate for everyone between just
between the ages of 8 and 80 you know it
doesn't have to be that way there can be
adult oriented art that is meaningful
and good but deals with difficult things
Dostoevsky
greatest novelist of all time in my
opinion his books are not for kids they
deal with death and murder and betrayal
and adultery and sex crime and
punishment one of the best novels ever
written period a great Christian novel
as well but it it starts the very first
chapter it starts with the protagonist
on his way to go murder an elderly woman
and the book describes that murder in
gory detail and it's very upsetting and
disturbing and it's supposed to be but
the whole point is you're not gonna read
that book and come away from it thinking
oh I'd like to be yeah I'd like to be
more like him I'd like to do what he did
it the beginning no that's not that's
you're gonna come to the exact opposite
conclusion and so that's I think that's
the important thing it's after you read
the book or watch the movie or watch the
show if if it depicted and dealt with
evil things does it make those evil
things seem appealing does it make you
feel like you want to try that stuff
yourself because it looks so cool and
everything sexy and everything based on
based on the way that it was portrayed
there are a lot of movies that do have
that effect which isn't to say that you
know watching a movie that glorifies
violence will cause someone to go and
commit violence it's not a as I said
yesterday it's the causal relationship
is not nearly that clear if there even
is any kind of call to causal
relationship but still it will have a
negative influence influence on us
psychologically and spiritually to watch
things that glorify violence and sin and
everything but if at
end of it you have the opposite feeling
where you feel repulsed and you feel
even more determined to avoid making the
mistakes and doing the things that you
saw the people in the show or the movie
doing then that means that it was not
glorified you know I don't think that
anyone could get to the end of Godfather
Part two when Michael Corleone is
standing there looking out the window as
his brother is being taken out you know
into the lake to be murdered and and and
you know and he's looking over his
empire that is of just death and
destruction where his family's gone his
wife hates them his kids hate him
his brothers dead he killed his brother
the other brothers dead I mean
everyone's dead and I don't think anyone
watches that and says themselves oh I
would really like to join the Mafia
so not glorification all right we will
but thank you for that emails definitely
it's it's an interesting discussion but
again you gotta you can't really
meaningfully participate in this
discussion if you've never watched any
of these things you just don't know what
you're talking about and and that's part
of the problem all right thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]